bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle journée de projectig avec
notamment Hikaru Nakamura je baisse mon
son salut Stéphane comment vas-tu
bonjour à tous salut Laurent j'espère
que tu vas bien donc gros gros match
aujourd'hui avec avec
icaruna Camorra et une très très grosse
équipe derrière on a vu un petit peu la
composition ah bah on va voir ça on va
découvrir ça j'ai juste tout préparé
alors évidemment c'est le c'est le
premier match avant l'équipe l'équipe
Bleach qui va faire son apparition juste
après
on suivra pas ce match mais ça sera à
suivre évidemment
sur sur Blist stream donc voilà avec
avec le capitaine d'équipe qui va qui va
vibrer normal pour son équipe une
victoire qui obligatoire d'ailleurs
contre les Croates ouais alors j'ai on a
fait une petite erreur hier et
d'ailleurs je vais la je vais je vais la
rectifier et on va regarder le
classement je vais aller chercher le
classement mais il y a des équipes qui
en trois sur trois les équipes qui ont 3
sur 3 je elle était en bonne en disant
elles étaient en bonne voie d'être
qualifiée et bien tu sais quoi on se
trompait parce qu'elles sont déjà
qualifiées donc quand on a 3 sur 3 en
fait ils font arrêter comme quand à zéro
sur 3 il considère que comme il y a 5
matchs ok en fait c'est toujours plus
donc il y aura moins de matchs la
semaine prochaine mais ils sont déjà
qualifiés et ce qui est en fait plutôt
très intelligent je trouve
de pas faire jouer les équipes qui sont
déjà qualifiées et en fait qui
pourraient choisir leurs adversaires en
fonction de leurs affinités
donc on va regarder tout de suite
l'équipe tu l'as dit donc cette appareil
de l'équipe américaine d'abord on va
voir l'équipe chinoise et justement
c'est les tombeurs de l'équipe de
blitzrim donc ça paye pas de mine comme
ça
veillez Niwa il y a pas de grande star
zangzong oh je connais depuis une
éternité zanzong Juventus la championne
du monde quand même
Xu qu'on avait vu aussi en fait pas de
grande star mais c'est quand même très
homogène cette histoire et puis ça gagne
tout simplement alors du coup par
rapport à tous les joueurs que vous avez
ici alors les joueurs qui sont qui sont
titulaires qui vont jouer aujourd'hui
donc on aura
Jul en deux on aura Xu et on aura Louis
typing en 4e c'est l'équipe qui met
depuis le début de la compétition
un joueur très fort devant
trois joueurs à
2005-2550 qui sont hyper solides et qui
crée de belles surprises depuis on va
voir on va voir tout ça et en face on
aura les Gotham Knights évidemment
emmené par
Ikao Nakamura le joueur le streamer le
super grand maître évidemment depuis de
nombreuses années celui qui se destinait
peut-être à une carrière de champion du
monde si manus quinzen avait pas existé
mais voilà ma muscarsen est là et il est
finalement il a basculé sur le carrière
de streamer qui est au moins qui est
disons au moins
qui est couronné de au moins en temps de
succès que sa carrière de joueurs il est
il est bon partout cet homme là
meilleur joueur du monde et puis au
nombre de vues aussi il fait des vues il
est fort
partout et donc qui jouera il jouera
alors j'ai aussi le regarde hop j'ai
aussi la compo Vladimir fait d'essence
Alina casting face à comme tu le disais
veilli Jouven June sourcils et Louis
ping il va falloir aller chercher
Ikaru Nakamura Vladimir faisaite très
très connu j'ai fait des petits matchs
avec lui à l'époque
à l'époque de chaise 24 partie like
Aussonne très très bon de joueurs de
blitzandes
Alina casting skyya la forte joueuse
d'origine russe qui est un main qui est
marié c'est la minute people qui est
marié grand maître international
polonais radeck voltachek et qui a opté
maintenant pour le drapeau polonais
suite au malheureux
événements évidemment cette guerre qui
fait rage encore aujourd'hui
et voilà donc elle est en Pologne et
elle joue pour la Pologne maintenant et
ensuite on a Mikola botnik alors tu m'as
parlé de Nicolas botnik alors j'ai pas
la rêve tu me disais qu'il était très
fort online alors il est ukrainien il a
2435 kg feed et j'ai vu qu'il avait 2600
hello en blitz feed et 3000 Francisco
donc en quatrième échiquier c'est quand
même assez costaud
la troisième bon bah Alina elle a elle a
2500 euros donc c'est aussi très très
costaud au niveau féminin ah c'est sûr
et là devant la deux monstres donc
légère avantage quand même sur les
féminines pour jouvaine jaune qui est
quand même bah championne du monde tout
simplement donc un peu meilleur mais que
Alina casting kayak qui a été
c'est vrai mais mais quand tu vois que
Joan zoom c'est quand même le numéro 2
de l'équipe
et que et que AlInAs c'est la Numéro 3
depuis le début on verra je t'avais dit
le premier match déjà je me suis rouler
chinois je sais pas j'ai pas trop mais
bon
quand même je méfie toujours des Chinois
et regarde regarde comment j'ai compris
ça parce que je suis allé voir parce que
je bosse les gens ils me croient pas
quand je dis que je bosse mais regarde
comment j'ai vu qu'ils étaient eux ils
sont éliminés les Charlotte collobois 0
sur 3 et là les Indian yogi trois
victoires hop en vert ça passe en quart
de finale et bravo à eux c'est les
premiers qualifiés et tu sais quoi je
vais te je vais te faire une une
tu as tout compris le gagnant de ce
match qu'on va qu'on va qu'on va qu'on
va choisir vraiment qu'on va commenter
surtout qu'on a pas choisi mais quand on
est ravi de commenter
entre les Shanghai Tigers et Gotham
Knights sera le deuxième qualifié de
cette ronde donc est-ce que c'est pareil
pour Blitz
donc Blitz il joue pour en fait il faut
avoir trois sur cinq mais si tu as 3 sur
3 c'est bon donc en fait il faut avoir
trois à un moment ou un autre donc pour
Blitz si il perde aujourd'hui on prend
le cas le pire il perdent et bien à ce
moment-là ils sont obligés de gagner les
deux derniers matchs si gagne ça donne
un peu de de quoi à respirer ça donne un
droit supplémentaire et donc ça leur
permet de jouer plus relax les prochains
matchs
écoute
on verra tout ça mais
je vais me noter les évidemment les noms
alors le début est toujours un petit peu
chaotique mais je vais me noter vous
voyez Alina casting skya sur l'image
alors en plus avec nos amis chinois
est-ce qu'elle aura les tu peux me
donner les appareils man s'il te plaît
apparemment c'est pas hors de la rendant
ouais j'ai pas les j'ai pas les couleurs
en fait on m'a pas donné
[Musique]
quels sont les joueurs le 2 c'est à
mettre Nicolas botnik a priori après je
te fais la ronde un je te fais p41
B41
parce qu'il faut que je les deux trucs
en même temps j'ouvre une zone
alors B4 c'est liping Louis pin qui aura
du coup les blancs quand on a qu'à la
rendre un
d'accord donc contre Naka que je vais
essayer de retrouver
alors attends mais déjà je retrouve
parce que là à chaque fois donc le 3 a
priori ça ressemble à une casse je sais
pas ce que tu en penses c'est la cave je
crois que c'est pas c'est pas sa vidéo
je crois tu crois
c'est lui mais il est pas encore arrivé
là le 4 c'est notre ami partie la queue
Ocean
et alors là on va être en galère parce
que tu sais pourquoi parce que
maintenant arrive nos amis chinois
c'est quand il s'appelle lui c'est quoi
son petit
[Musique]
je le reconnais il est où là
ça joue à 19h 19h ça sera à suivre pas
ici mais sur la chaîne
blitzrim donc n'hésitez pas à aller
encourager évidemment
nos amis est le 5 Louis pink c'est ça
par déduction c'est le hipping
à moins que ça soit
lui c'est le mi- ouais je crois c'est
Louis pink alors donc la première partie
qui va commencer ça va être celle du
carreau Nakamura qui aura donc les Noirs
c'est ça contre contre
tout de suite à l'écran donc en fait si
tu veux les BP c'est les Chinois
et je sais bien c'est américain voilà
comme américain
et donc du coup non
[Musique]
celle que je connais pas physiquement
c'est lui ils ont encore changé alors on
a qu'à il est en 1
non on a quand il est en deux
ah ils m'ont changé encore là le truc en
cours de route donc de Naka
pardon pardon je me ah c'était Alina
casting skya qui a été plusieurs fois
championne olympique un papier mais tu
sais que tu pourrais juste faire clic
droit renommer et marquer la je sais ce
que je fais moi c'est plus simple
ah ouais mais moi je suis très papier
tant que je peux utiliser encore un peu
de papier je le fais
je sais que c'est pas bien je sais que
c'est pas archi moderne
je le comprends mais qu'est-ce que tu
veux c'est bon c'est mon péché mignon
donc on va voir ikonakamura on rappelle
il avait une surprise
il y avait une surprise pour
la première onde contre Joséphine einman
bon maintenant il est prévenu et depuis
ça déroule comme chez Magnus Carlsen 11
surdou chez manuscrite sur 8 carreaux
donc
il est impressionnant et chez blistry
bon c'est pas qui c'est qui aura pour
pour commenter
[Musique]
qui verra son épouse joué et voilà belle
équipe hein chez les chez l'équipe Blitz
avec Sacha gritchouk le joueur bah il
était présenté moi j'ai joué pour la
première fois contre lui en
2000 mes chers amis étaient présentés
comme le prochain champion du monde par
nos amis russes
[Musique]
donc ça ça tombe bien ça donne vraiment
envie d'être pour eux en fait tu vois
parce que parfois tu as des gens tu as
des gens très fort mais bon pas
forcément les plus sympas mais là ils
sont c'est tous des crèmes donc on a
fond pour eux alors on espère que ça a
commencé alors
et figure-toi qu'il l'est pas encore il
est pas encore encore ça va
alors il est là non moi je vois que
oui
c'est contre fais de CF j'ai trois
parties est-ce que Nakamura
est noire contre le Louis pink il est
pas connecté alors est-ce que ça pendule
ou pas
ouais donc toi il y a marqué 9,50 moi
j'ai 9 08 là 9 0 8 OK
et
on va voir
salut Kevin salut à tous est-ce que le
son est bon dites-nous parce que j'ai
voulu faire un test et ça foiré
complètement le test j'ai harcelé ce
pauvre stouf vas-y Fabien en fait test
et tout ça et puis je sais pas du tout
réussi à le faire j'entend derrière sur
le test donc est-ce que le son est mieux
là est-ce qu'on est plus disons sur les
mêmes sur les mêmes zones et on voit
Ikaru Nakamura qui est là et qui qui
stream comme d'hab alors pourquoi j'ai
pas les j'ai pas les coups en tout cas
il parle
il est pas dans son studio non il y a un
truc là
ouais il joue déjà mais je vois pas la
partie là
d'accord tu fais des cigarettes il a
joué allez on va voir on va voir
évidemment on passera la majorité de
notre temps je suppose chez chez Iker un
Nakamura mais on va voir Souilly donc
notre ami
souillé avec les Blancs cette fois c'est
ça on est d'accord ouais avec les Blancs
face à
[Musique]
face
j'avais adoré son pseudo très très fan
de fée de CF hein qui est un peu un
wildo fait de CF mais un werdo sympa tu
vois un mec un peu bizarre mais mais
marrant quoi il fait des trucs
je vais faire des trucs que j'ai jamais
vu jamais vu dans d'autres
[Musique]
j'ai rarement vu quoi en tout cas donc
pardon
anecdote elle nous raconte quoi
et à ses copains quoi ça le faisait rire
bon j'ai fait nulle c'est un peu bizarre
quoi quand même pression bon et deuxième
fois il a fini 3e un championnat
d'Europe
et en fait il allait au sur le podium et
il s'applaudissait en même temps ce qui
donnait
un petit peu bizarre mais bon c'est un
bon résultat donc en même temps il y
avait il y avait il y avait de quoi
s'applaudir mais c'est pas un truc que
tu vois tous les jours je sais pas c'est
clair
donc voilà
plutôt mais pas tu vois tu sentais qu'il
le faisait pas par et c'était pas de
arrogance ou c'était j'étais content
quoi
c'est un peu comme les comme les gens
qui like leur leur propre publication
sur Facebook
dans le chat on va se faire des amis
mais il faut dire que ouais les codes
sociaux normalement font que on se on
like pas mais bon après beaucoup de
codes sociaux c'est comme ça mais
normalement là il peut pas ça propre
publication on dit pas je m'aime bien
c'est pas mal ce que j'ai fait quoi mais
donc s'il y en a qui font dans le chat
arrêté franchement c'est un peu
c'est un peu ridicule alors on a un
fouet
mais mettez-nous un petit like sur la
vidéo et d'ailleurs moi c'est le premier
truc que je fais je l'avoue ce truc
quand je programme un show je mets un
petit like
tu vois direct sur YouTube
tu vois ah oui mais sur Youtube
c'est parce que je vois pas que je fais
parce que personne ne sait que que je le
fais en fait je viens de me voilà de
motos balancer là mais bon mais je le
fais tu vois ne faites pas ça se voit
parce que ça se voit par contre ça se
voit pas ben les gars fais ce que vous
voulez en fait c'est très bien vous
pouvez vous regarder dans la glace
pendant une demi-heure tous les matins
mais il faut pas faut personne soit là
c'est ça le truc
donc fou B2 à 6 qu'est-ce que ça donne
cette histoire et bien fait de CF qui
joue un peu B5 un petit peu dans le
désert on sait pas trop à quoi ça sert
ça empêche un petit peu ces quatre c'est
vrai mais pourquoi pas après tout ça
joue B2 à 6 ça casse ça crée une petite
cible là pour les pour les Noirs va
falloir pour les blancs on va faire
quelque chose est-ce qu'on fait
je perds mon écouteur excusez-moi est-ce
que on fait des trois ou des quatre
souffle ici qu'est-ce que tu ferais
je sais pas
des quatre j'ai peur pour la colonne C
plus tard
les noirs auraient pris et ensuite petit
coup de tour C8 et c'est vrai que ce
pion peut se retrouver assez faible mais
bon ça manque de bon c'est un truc avec
fouber 5 échecs donc ça manque de peps
pour les blancs c'est une partie très
confortable pour les noirs et pour les
blancs d'ailleurs on va aller voir
peut-être le duel des des joueuses qu'on
est habitués d'ailleurs d'habitude on va
voir en dernier évidemment mais
pas cette fois avec Alina kaschline
Skyla qui a donc les blancs et on va
aller tout de suite la voir voilà Alina
très concentrée face à Juventus qui
rigolait avant la le début du de la
partie tranquillement on la voit la
championne du monde elle attend
tranquillement de connaître son
adversaire pour le match qui arrivera on
sait pas quand
et on a une variante Nîmes invovic donc
qui est dite de ces miches c'est à dire
qu'on fait à 3 on dit va-t'en prends-moi
et maintenant j'ai de fous mais j'ai une
mauvaise structure et on retarde
développement mais je vais essayer de je
vais pour le max c'est à dire je vais
essayer d'occuper le centre et de
massacrer
donc il y a plein de problèmes sur
l'option C4 on va voir un peu comment il
y a eu il y a eu un petit ok
souvent
c'est quand le donne pour l'initiative
on est prêt à donner spion parce qu'on
peut avoir beaucoup de jeux donc sur F4
ouais le cours recommandé c'est de faire
F5 d'empêcher une avalanche qui peut
arriver et puis on prend puis on prend
et maintenant on a un vrai problème sur
ce pion C4 sur KG3 en général
il semble que c'est de la théorie tout
ça ok j'ai trop en fait G6 pour protéger
ici et ensuite on va essayer d'encaisser
spions sur dame 2 et un coup très
thématique ici c'est qui est de faire C5
pas contre ce fou et on va peut-être
envisager de faire cailler les 6 filles
de cahier prend ces quatre toujours
pareil ça te faiblesse en C4 et c'est
pas clair comment les blancs vont
continuer la TAC si on peut parler
d'attaque à l'endroit
intéressant et on a ensuite veillé
ou contre botnik alors là
[Musique]
il est où il est où notre ami veilli
noir
il y a une paire de fou pour le pour les
Noirs mais un petit pion passé faire
attention là
tout à fait et en fait je connais cette
ligne parce que j'ai regardé pour mon
j'en parlais hier
alors je vais te dire tous mes secrets
alors c'est 3 kf3d 6 moi je recommande
ça dans mon compte chez sebbel ok mais
regarde ça retombe
ça retombe fous ces quatre pions prend
ouais c'est ce que je recommande faut
prendre à me prendre et c'est trop Dame
des 6 des 5 clés et des 4 qui est propre
puis on prend un me prend E5 c'est
exactement mon cours de chelseables mes
chers amis
bah écoute voyez le fichier je crois
par contre j'ai pas regardé
je crois moi
alors et à me faire bosser voilà ah ben
c'est bien ça bravo merci
fait plaisir
les deux fous pour les Noirs ça peut
devenir très très vite très très bon
pour les Noirs par contre c'est hyper
bizarre quand tu vois le temps tu vois
que porter qui a 9 51 et que Wailly à 3
minutes et je pense qu'il fait que mon
téléphone il a un problème d'internet là
ou quoi
alors ça c'est interdit mais en tout cas
vous inquiétez pas veillez au courant il
a il tripote son téléphone alors je sais
pas ce qui se passe mais il y a un truc
il y a un problème de il y a un problème
de CO on sait pas trop ce qui se passe
ouais parce que là c'est juste
c'est évidemment interdit d'avoir son
téléphone pendant la partie où vous
soyez d'ailleurs en vrai ou sur Internet
mais là il y a un vrai problème côté
veillé
quoi
ce qui se passe
non bah disons votre
studio on dirait un studio de photos ou
je sais pas quoi il est pas mal là
j'ai vu qu'il avait une page twitch et
il avait que deux vidéos et il l'a fait
la semaine dernière d'accord
[Musique]
il a un beau studio des belles
conditions en tout cas et par contre vie
on sait pas trop ce qui se passe bon on
garde un œil sur ça
et Nakamura
c'est bizarre cette histoire parce que
sinon
ça va être beau ce match ouais alors je
pense qu'on s'avance un petit peu là
mais ouais mais bon enfin un accueil
joue pas la partie terre a été annulée
parce qu'on voit que ah si le temps d'un
aka c'est cool
je vais aller voir sur sur un TASCOM
international
j'ai un lien je vais sentir
donc on va revenir à l'ancienne
et hop
et non j'ai pas de partie donc on
regarde VI là qui a joué dame B8
apparemment mais très très bizarre cette
histoire
la mes 8 tours par le streamer
ukrainien on a ce des 6 ça doit être
parti perdu
en photo non mais là enfin tu vois si
quelqu'un voulait tricher je pense qu'il
le ferait plus discrètement donc là il y
a quand même eu un truc là
et un problème d'internet il devait il
devait parler pour voir
voilà tout à fait raison évidemment
oui non mais bien sûr bien sûr il y a
aucun dans un truc de projectiles
dans tous les domaines dans tous les
sports où vous voulez c'est jamais
complètement zéro mais c'est très très
improbable c'est comme ça c'est dans la
vie en général qu'est-ce que vous voulez
ça fout des deux menaces cavalier prend
et fou B4
ramasse la qualité donc petite
initiative pour les blancs bon ben 4 je
regarderai pour ceux qui achèteront mon
cours d'avocate la solution sera dans le
cours de chez sebul qui va sortir on
sait pas
ça surprise
pour tout le monde et pour moi inclus on
sait pas encore c'est 2023 2024
pour les JO voilà allez
jouer ah oui la F5
F5
qui peut partir avec la découverte c'est
ça qui était trop tour huit et le coup
pour faire foudre pour empêcher ce
cahier prend des 6 fut B4 avec la tour
qui traîne derrière donc c'est bien joué
peut-être qu'il est passé en 4G oui tout
à fait
[Musique]
alors après je peux essayer de tenir
j'ai l'impression à toujours [__] que
reposer donc ça favorise la nul mais
effectivement ça peut aller vite aussi
c'est mieux pour les blancs c'est clair
un peu décevant déjà pour pour nos amis
chinois avec veille qui a pas bon il est
clairement un problème il a été il était
gêné par quelque chose tu auras CE1 a
été joué foudé 7
toujours pas de nouvelles toujours pas
ikarunakamura le streamer américain
cette partie qu'on a pas du tout vu mais
évidemment évidemment qu'on va suivre en
priorité notre ami notre ami
car unakamura qui est quand même la star
ça c'est sûr de
ce match ouais je vais le mettre tout de
suite donc on voit déjà un petit
problème de roi chez les Blancs
aussi pas mal et 4 minutes compte 3 on
aura raté le début
et ce petit pion il va pas être il va
pas être défendable non il est pas
défendable alors est-ce qu'on peut s'en
sortir comme ça
pas très marrant
en fait c'est pas que c'est pas très
marrant c'est qu'on va la perdre donc il
faudrait essayer de trouver quelque
chose de mieux
est-ce que ça existe c'est ça le
problème Dame des cinq jouets par
loyipping qui va essayer de tenir
le roi est faible
et c'est joué
peut-être un peu de toute façon
si les pions Béa n'existaient pas et
bien je te dis avec une beaucoup de
certitudes que normalement ça doit être
nul le résultat objectif mais avec les
pions A et B
je trouve ça chaud à défendre et puis la
tour C4 elle est plus active que que les
tournures que le Tour Blanche et on fixe
avec la prise en C4 du pion ça crée
et voilà on met tout sur blanc voyez
contre le foot case noire qui va qui va
taper dans du vide et attention ce fout
maintenant on avait finale de fou en
ramasse en ramasse la petite famille
donc c'est très chaud je pense qu'il va
jouer il faut qu'il fasse attention à F4
c'est tout je pense que c'est le dernier
truc par exemple ça ça il y a une petite
chance de sauver s'il faut pas en fout
prend pour prendre et on va prendre des
six à la fin avec la 600 heures derrière
mais évidemment que Hikaru c'est pas il
est pas né hier et donc il est au
courant de tout ça et sur F4 il veut
simplement faire [__] on reprend et je
t'attaque le pion et ça fait depuis ça
fait un peu trop cher et du coup tout
refait 5 ou est-ce que c'est trop
G4
mais en fait je te dis non parce que
j'ai vu son coup d'après en fait il
voulait faire au F7 ramener le roi
d'abord tour E4 et roi E6 il
caronakamura qui connaît les vieux
principes on ramène le roi au centre
on fait jouer
salut
on est d'accord
en quelques instants
ouais il fait il fait ça aussi mais
c'est pas son entre autres
comme disent exactement
quel rôle plutôt c'est plutôt tout ce
qui est bon c'est les réseaux sociaux
aussi mais c'est aussi les articles
articles les traductions et tout ça
bah si je gère tous les réseaux comme
sauf toi aussi quand même maintenant
quand même
aussi aussi ouais les articles
de Facebook notamment de tous les
réseaux plus plus d'autres choses
d'accord bon bah super
alors poussez trois
je me rappelle qu'à Chartres il faisait
des très bons articles de c'est à
longtemps
j'ai dit pourquoi on n'a pas les
articles comme ça non
j'en profite pour engueuler pour
ta faute
pas les articles comme ça donc
tout a envie d'avant de tout en faisant
rien moi-même évidemment
donc faut prendre et il est rentré dans
cette finale de tour
je me rappelle
D5 et là ça va commencer à dérouler là
tu es sûr avec le roi comme ça ouais ça
gagne parce que le roi est coupé quand
même ça ça peut être c'est vrai que
il faut encore travailler mais
[Musique]
ah bah oui au final complètement
dégueulasse pour ami chinois oui ça
c'est moi qu'on puisse dire est-ce qu'il
peut dégueulasse c'est une chose est-ce
que les perdante ou pas probablement il
y avait une
idée marrante avec avec tours c'est un
tour 1 et 3
mais ouais mais nakaïs
ouais c'est pas mal ce truc le mode des
deux tours mais effectivement
il se fatigue pas et vas-y je te je te
mets le roi je te mets la tour et je te
pousse le pion je t'encaisse le pion
peut-être au passage
bon ça a l'air quand même ça a l'air de
le faire pour
ce deuxième pion je peux dire que la
maison n'a qu'à ne fait pas crédit et
ensuite il va faire il va pousser tout
ça le roi est beaucoup trop loin alors
évidemment il va il va reprendre le pion
G
le joueur chinois mais ça sera très
nettement et suffisant
trop de pions passé même si tu manges
depuis Angers en fait tu te rends en
avance il pousse
pour calculer
le ROI et surtout reprendre il va faire
ça à mon avis
[Musique]
OK
assistant
il va faire et redescin qui voulait
faire tourner je suppose
OK
[Musique]
que je montre c'est jouer d'ailleurs
tour à trois tours F4 roi.g5 tour des 4
tours un seul coup et la tour est
beaucoup trop passif pour qu'il se passe
quoi que ce soit Roger 5 ah non il prend
F3 je vous l'avais dit qu'on a comme moi
il faisait pas crédible en général c'est
parti et tu auras de jouer mais ouais
bon alors je trouve que la conversion a
pas été géniale mais bon c'est pinailler
là tellement
très largement gagnant trois B3 bien
joué comme ça surtout des dons on fait
roi C3 et surtout un des deux
et on reprend ouais c'est de et terminer
on sait que je dois gagner sa partie
ça commence très bien pour
pour Gotham est-ce qu'on n'irait pas
voir voilà il va essayer c'est abandon
on va voir peut-être jouer une chose qui
pourra porter un point
un point au
à l'équipe chinoise parce que ça fait
déjà 2-0 quand même mine de rien et je
suis sûr que oui il lui reste 5 secondes
à la pendule tu m'étonnes et tes déco il
était déco la majorité de la partie avec
Alina qui est là
c'est quoi je vais je vais faire ta
méthode je vais mettre les noms je crois
que tu as raison là c'est plus simple je
crois et c'est plus rapide en fait c'est
ça surtout que ça soit plus simple moi
ça me plaît pas particulièrement que ce
soit plus simple mais que ça soit plus
rapide ça ça me plaît ouais non mais
juste au début de la caméra tu regardes
qui est qui tu changes le nom et puis
c'est bon hein je vais faire ça
c'est pas comme avec Kevin avec avec
Monsieur Pro Évolution échec j'apprends
rien avec toi j'apprends tu vois avec
lui et j'apprends jamais rien c'est
quand même
c'est un truc régulier
bon ça ça gagne et alors
nique notre ami
on dirait qu'il est
sa photographe professionnelle votre mec
complètement et
qui doit être là alors il est sans
téléphone cette fois ah qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé
le fou en prise portnique
contre quatre secondes pas le droit de
donner le fou comme ça elle était
bizarre cette partie de toute façon on
vous met la fin de de cacher une
skaillage ou une journée ça sera fini
bientôt on va renommer tout ça
et bon du coup en fait ok il y a eu un
bug chez Wailly mais en fait on peut
dire quand même que ce qui est pas eu de
bug normalement vous voyez tu es quand
même largement favori bien sûr du coup
ça ça change pas grand chose c'est vrai
que porter qui aurait pu profiter de de
tous ces problèmes pour essayer parce
qu'il a fait il avait la pression mais
c'est dommage quand même de terminer
comme ça de donner le fou en un coup et
bon c'est le jeu donc tu confirme ça
fait deux deux donc score logique au
final dans ce premier set
et on va voir du coup des appareils pour
la ronde 2 alors
attends attends je change les trucs là
je suis pas multitâche
pour l'instant enfin personne ne le voit
mais moi je change pour moi 7 + 5 le
joueur 4 je crois que c'était c'était
bon
mais il faut pas que je me gourde tu
vois sinon ça serait quand même
ce serait pas une grosse performance de
ma part
ouais c'est ça au pire ouais au pire il
y a que toi qui le voit oui je sais bien
mais du coup ça me
botanique et Naka que j'ai mis les noms
ça a commencé à être compliqué à gérer
tout ça
cette histoire et je vais quitter ma
feuille de papier ça me ça me fait mal
au cœur mais bon moi je faisais comme
toi mais au final c'était quand même
bien mieux ouais je crois que tu as
raison
je suis je suis converti
je suis bien tu me prends et tu parfois
tu es un peu trop habitué à être avec
Kevin parce que tu dis il y a que toi
qui le vois je sais bien qu'il voit
quand même
c'est quand même c'est pas très sympa de
ta part de me confondre avec Kevin bon
j'apprécie moyennement je te le dis je
préfère que les choses soient claires
parce que franchement je sais qu'il y a
moi qui le voit alors vas-y on va voir
les appâts alors salut Yume
bienvenue à toi
tout à fait
on a qui
donc
entre
tout type sushi j'arrive pas à le dire
entre sushi
d'accord bon ben toute façon ouais les
autres on les verra après on se changera
de partie mais on va commencer par les
caronakamura je pense qui va commencer
en premier s'il y a pas de problème je
sais pas pourquoi il se déconnecte à
chaque fois
c'est bizarre
je vais voir si je peux ouvrir le lien
de mon côté voir si je le vois aussi
est-ce qu'on irait pas voir un petit
récap pour ceux qui viennent de
faire une sieste ou de nous rejoindre on
sait pas est-ce qu'on prépare un petit
récap format yes alors du coup un petit
peu tout comment ça se passe alors
comment ça se passe c'est du cadence 10
+ 2 il y a 16 équipes
ça peut pas dépasser 2550 de moyenneo
sachant que c'est capé qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire être capé c'est-à-dire que
quand on a 2700 et 2700 ou 3500 ça ne
change rien on comme en 200700 et pour
les joueuses c'est 2350 c'est à dire que
oui fan contré comme une 2350 donc
évidemment c'est génial de l'avoir dans
son équipe on affronte tous les joueurs
pour un total de 4 ans ce qui donne des
appariements parfois comme on a vu hier
avec Marcus Carcel face à cari saïip
qu'elle a fait une très très grosse
partie elle a failli faire nul contre
l'ogre norvégien
première équipe à 8 et demi en porte de
match et en cas d'égalité c'est là où tu
vas tout nous dire Stéphane comment ça
se passe en cas d'égalité du coup on
fait le remake de la partie je lis ton
truc donc on prend les mêmes Paris monde
de la dernière ronde invente et en fait
voilà on va changer les couleurs et on
joue en 3 + 2 et si jamais il y a un
nouveau match nul et ben on fait la même
chose on change les couleurs et on passe
en une plus de jusqu'à ce que il y ait
une équipe qui gagne un match donc ça
peut durer toute la nuit
si l'égalité perdure mais normalement je
pense que à un moment donné on Bullet
bon il y a quand même des
matchs qui vont
[Musique]
qui vont se terminer est-ce que c'est
bien que ça soit ouais au début de débat
en tout cas mon créé mon gré followay
qui nous dit j'aime pas trop le fait que
ça soit capé c'est vrai que ça ça fausse
un petit peu le truc mais ça avantage
disons
disons ça incite à avoir des joueurs les
plus fort possible et ça incite à avoir
et carunakamura Magnus Carlsen dans
cette ligue Fabienne ukawana donc c'est
compréhensible aussi on est plutôt
content de les avoir évidemment j'aime
bien le fait que ce soit capé aussi pour
les filles parce que c'est vrai que là
c'est aussi les meilleurs joueuses
avenir et puis en fait au final des
équipes qui sont l'équipe place des
carreaux quand même elle est costaud
mondial tu as fait d'eau qui est
top 30
féminin en fait bon et mes collaborking
c'est un très fort ami enfin c'est un
ami qui est très très bon emblème
parfois il oublie les pièces par contre
un peu trop confiance je crois mais mais
sinon c'est c'est une superbe équipe
quoi franchement la plus grosse équipe
qu'on avait vu jusque là et ouais ouais
non
peut-être peut-être il y a beaucoup il y
a beaucoup de très bonnes équipes c'est
très dur à dire
pour pour ceux qui veulent suivre ça
allez encourager les les Français
évidemment on espère qu'ils vont aller
loin et ils peuvent aller loin et après
une fois que tu es dans les 8 premiers
c'est du knokke-out donc on sait c'est
la magie des des éliminations directes
finalement ça joue sur à chaque fois
trois fois rien et ça peut tomber ça
peut tourner en notre faveur évidemment
donc
l'essentiel là sera de gagner pour
essayer alors une défaite n'est pas
éliminatoire mais attention une défaite
ça veut dire qu'il faut gagner les deux
matchs suivants donc ça veut dire qu'on
se on se grille un joker dans ce grille
un droit à l'erreur et donc une victoire
aujourd'hui serait
mais très l'équipe Blitz dans une
position beaucoup plus confortable quand
à la suite du tournoi
donc 19h chez des stream tout à l'heure
elles sont pas diminuées ils ont un sur
deux
matchs c'est pas c'est pas direct c'est
vraiment c'est un mini championnat on
peut pas appeler ça un championnat
vraiment
vraiment très très fort mais enfin je
veux dire on peut pas un championnat à
part entière c'est un championnat très
très fort mais c'est c'est pas un
championnat à part entière où on va
jouer contre toutes les autres équipes
et tout ça c'est que c'est sur cinq
semaines dans 5 matchs et ensuite de
l'immiation directe c'est le spectacle
on joue pas c'est pas un championnat de
Top 16 où on joue on marque même en Top
16 je peux pas les 15 autres équipes
mais on joue 11 matchs quand même
remarque là si tu pour gagner il faut
gagner en fait c'est un ne remarque
Indian new grise peut-être qu'ils vont
gagner 6 7 matchs mais enfin bon c'est
que ça reste quand même très quelque
chose de très dynamique et de très beau
et bah qui joue à l'équipe française
ouais mais alors bah qui il a le même
problème que moi c'est c'est pas une
bonne affaire quand tu sais que il a
2650 et qu'à 2700 c'est capé il vaut
mieux il vaut mieux avoir des joueurs à
2750 c'est des meilleurs affaires donc
les joueurs à 2006 sont pas sont pas du
tout des bonnes affaires dans ce genre
de compète
je sais pas ce que tu en penses
on a vu les Américains hier qui
mettaient toujours une féminine en 2002
et qui mettait le paquet en fait dans
les forts joueurs ils mettaient de 2016
c'est un 26 50 en fait pour après mettre
une féminine à 2002 et qui va
normalement quasiment tout perdre mais
il compte sur les joueurs du milieu de
tableau voir en tête pour gagner
donc voilà ça dépend vraiment comment tu
veux jouer parce que tu veux faire cette
cette méthode là en fait c'est
intéressant finalement genre toi tu
joues au 3 ça va quoi tu vois qu'on peut
faire tu peux faire ça aussi parce que
bon aux deux c'est vrai que ok tu peux
prendre un 2016 50 un jeune etc bon mais
au 3 ça va quand même
ça se tient effectivement bon quand on a
l'option my Boyer
elle est pas mal cette option aussi moi
j'aime bien
beaucoup de sens avec deux monstres de
premier Maëlle Boyer et une très forte
féminine pour compléter l'équipe moi
j'aime bien la gueule de l'équipe alors
après il se trouve que
gretchu que tout le respect l'amitié que
j'ai pour Sacha c'est pas Carson voilà
et alors ça serait la même chose en fait
d'avoir quelque chose que personne mais
bon après voilà
tu mets cette équipe ouais après il y a
27 et 27
parce que il y a 2007 qui sont plus
forts que d'autres sur Internet ou plus
stable et c'est vrai que tu as bon ok
bon on va enlever un peu car ça n'en aka
qui sont un peu pour moi là un peu au
dessus et qui rase complètement
championnat
qu'est-ce qui en a comme 2007 qui peut
être très dangereux genre un irriguez ça
peut être ça peut être dangereux
c'est pas mal
carwana l'autre fois il a fait trois
quatre je crois aussi
alors quand tu prends par exemple on a
vu l'autre jour un pragalanda qui est
qui au 1 aussi bah pour moi c'est quand
même pas aussi fort que qu'un renard ou
tu vois donc en fait ça dépend de ton
2007 quand même je pense qu'il faut tu
peux être malin quoi
ouais bon faut voir après c'est en
fonction des affinités aussi et on va
voir
icarunakamura qui qui joue cette ligne
là c'est la ligne de Magnus et qu'il a
joué deux fois en mode champion du monde
et oui cavalier 4 Fabienne avait joué
cavalier C6
et après qui est des 5 ça peut être ça
peut être une pagaille indescriptible ce
truc là c'est assez marrant qu'il y a
des quatre qui prend cette caille prend
un deux Magnus avait joué je pense
et là je sais plus ce que c'est le coup
je me rappelle plus voilà c'est l'âge et
pourtant il a joué en mode champion du
monde cette histoire
ouais ouais
exactement ouais c'est ça c'est ça tout
à fait tout à fait un truc et là je sais
plus ce qu'on fait mais voilà il y a la
vente simple aussi c'est de faire ces 6
directs et effectivement c'est 6 direct
est quand même beaucoup beaucoup plus
simple et tout à fait tout à fait
convenable pour les noirs et c'est ce
qu'avait fait Magnus contre Yann n'est
pas parce que ce qu'a joué Yann des
pommiers à chier ensuite dans le dernier
match
un petit peu similaire entre c'était pas
carcenouda au tata si si il aime bien
c'est possible que Carlson est encore
joué ça il ajouta
au tata style ah oui c'est ça ouais tout
à fait tout à fait ah il l'aime bien
cette variante
bon c'est pas très il y a pas grand
chose mais ça reste ça reste une petite
finale technique en général on va
échanger les dames et voilà on va mettre
quelque chose pour prendre de l'espace
il a joué ça depuis fin à chaque fois
que je le vois avec tout le temps la
même donc il a attendu je pense quand
même sur sa
russe
3 tu vois il veut pas il veut pas
changer les dames il car unakamura ok
intéressant
c'est intéressant ça c'est une pétrophe
c'est pas c'est pas flamboyant tout ça
alors
[Musique]
tout à fait tout à fait elle se
ressemble à part que là il reste encore
les dames qui changent quand même pas
mal de choses mais je crois qu'il va
jouer pareil il va jouer avec qui est
BD7 et grand rock quelque chose comme ça
peut-être cavalier assise
et pas forcément
idiot
et comment est-ce qu'on joue la tête
d'un mec de foulée 3 ou la dame va venir
un F2
peut-être vous des trois peut-être
Tourer il a joué dans ma vidéo assez
rapidement bon léger grand remarque
est-ce que c'est un léger plus ça pour
les blancs ou pas peut-être
mais alors si c'est quelque chose c'est
très léger en tout cas
un petit tour un petit tour des stades
allez avec ma nouvelle méthode donc
Louis pink c'est vachement plus rapide
faut avouer que faut avouer que c'est le
jour à la nuit quand même Louis pince
donc on a une berlinoise ah ben alors ça
je la connais cette ligne petit ok il
prend quatre tours
il est voilà
un peu de théorie on fait non j'ai joué
à 6 pardon pardon pour moi j'ai joué à 6
d'abord faut F1 et ensuite 4 c'est
normalement la
qui est censée être jouable il y a une
partie très récente entre les von a
rognan et anishbiri ou
Annie je guerrier avait résolu ses
points d'ouverture mais c'est incliné
face à Levon a rognan mais il faut faire
un petit peu attention si on connaît pas
trop avec les noix on peut se retrouver
assez vite mal et là typiquement je
crois que de pas avoir joué à 6 c'est
pas terrible pour les pour les Noirs
parce que maintenant si on fait assis on
a donné l'option de prendre en C6 objets
de reprendre du pion B et voilà un petit
coup de cavalier au 5 étudier tu vas
faire un couple tu as pas envie de faire
un truc comme ça ou un truc comme ça un
truc moche
donc petite imprécision à mon avis du
joueur du joueur chinois ces trois fous
des 6 et là on voit que sur même sur A6
le fou peut revenir peut gagner du temps
et revenir en Détroit alors qu'en
général tu te mets en effet un d'abord
et ensuite tu reviens en Détroit plus
tard donc
Georges chinois qui a joué vite mais on
ouvre pas enfin je pense qu'il connaît
pas trop et en fait il a juste prendre
le prix de partie de jouer assez vite
après ça reste quand même solide mais
c'est vrai que c'est une micro finesse
oui effectivement ça reste une position
symétrique quand même
intéressant et on va aller voir donc
quels Caya qui joue contre
les Blancs
face à cacher une skya
Alina de son prénom
je guide 2007 la même plus que 2016
tout à fait
et par rapport à Houilles maintenant
même si elle joue plus trop échecs voilà
pas été huitième mondiale non je crois
qu'elle a fait maintenant
on avait quasiment 2007 hein
quand même hein
elle avait un potentiel de nettement
au-dessus de 2007 clairement
à 18 ans tu vois enfin bon santé
que ça pouvait aller beaucoup plus haut
cette histoire
et là on avait eu contre cashing skya
victoire quasi impérative là pour les
pour les Chinois sur cet échiquier
tellement c'est déséquilibré sur le
papier
petit rock y a eu pour la Benoni hein
c'est toujours mauvais on le sait
c'est une poubelle la Mélanie à haut
niveau c'est dur hein
c'est pas une exception cette position
elle a une poubelle intersidérale qui
essaie 4 qui peut jouer qui est B6
son mari a tellement beau répertoire
elle pourrait qu'elle copie
tu sais que F4 existe aussi F4 pour
mettre la totale après faut faire
attention à genre de truc que j'avais
pas vu ok je sais pas
très mauvaise position pour Alina
casting skyya ça c'est sûr et on a
botnik face à juventjun qui est depuis
le début fait des je trouve semble
qu'elle fait des grosses journées à
chaque fois
j'ouvre un June ah non elle a les blancs
je peux te dire ça
apparaître sous vos yeux ébahis et on
voit une catalane fougée de fous d'essai
de la part de botnik ok
pas très bonne réputation
voilà ne se passe comme ça
et apparemment c'est complètement
gagnant pour les blancs mais c'est pas
une grosse surprise qu'est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer que j'ai cinq ici mais dans ce
cavaliers aussi
d'abord pour jouer cavalier un temps sur
la dame avec foi je crois
tourner un alors
du coup dame C8 est la cavalier 5 et tu
vas avoir foi avec un tempo il n'aime
pas cavalier 5 à chaque fois
tellement gagnant de toute façon
une pièce de moins après tout je peux
pousser aussi
ce que je peux trouver un truc
intelligent pour te clouer genre un truc
comme ça maintenant j'ai envie de se
servir de faire un chèque et G5
villageois pas être contente
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais je peux jouer ça
ouais c'est ça
on a quand même des pions déjà
ça va pas ça va pas
il faut jouer alors
ça c'est bien
mais ça n'a pas l'air c'est simple quand
même une pièce de plus
il y a une énorme énorme
on prend les blancs tous les jours
qu'elle en pense menace wash 3 mais tu
sais quoi la jauge elle aime pas mais tu
vas voir ah on va on va attendre le coup
de de botnique mais ça m'étonnerait pas
à mon avis dans trois coups elle est
gagnante
bientôt ouais parce que c'est tellement
dur à jouer ce genre de truc je sais pas
ce que c'est le coup là pour les Noirs
mais franchement
peut-être qu'il faut juste jouer à 6
faut c'est fou H3 et prendre J5 et tu
manges toutes tes pièces
pour la dame
j'ai même plus besoin de te pousser dans
la mauvaise position en fait tu le fais
de toi même ce que j'apprécie
particulièrement
si tu prends direct la mauvaise position
c'est bien
on va bien s'entendre on va bien
s'entendre t'inquiète pas 5 j'ai dame 4
ensuite
qu'est-ce que tu fais franchement
victoire alors
qu'est-ce qu'on joue alors à jouer et
ouais
pour ramener ses faux cran G5
[Musique]
faire cavalier j'ai 4 ou un truc comme
ça
enfin jusqu'à Vallier quoi
non H6 x 3 et qui est BD7 a été joué
c'est dangereux certes
mais quoi d'autre en même temps et
maintenant comment on fait c'est pas si
simple cavaler aussi trois points F7 ok
on survit pour l'instant
comment on peut faire sinon le 5
la justice ou d'un F5 alors le 5G
j'ai pas tout reprendre
pareil en X j'ai presque 8
mais ça marche pas
marché aussi mais ça marche pas
en fait jouer roi F7 et d'un prince C3
que ça peut faire mal cette histoire
qui qui rigole pendant qu'ils jouent
chaque fois ils sont des contraintes on
l'a vu souvent la même manière encore
les joueurs qui sourient pendant qu'ils
jouent alors que porter qui sourit pas
trop tu vois
il vient de mettre une pièce en prises à
partir d'avant
c'est toujours pareil il y a un contexte
et du coup
[Musique]
la position noire il y a rien qui tient
quoi alors que les blancs en fait c'est
hyper naturel
tout rentre un peu comment du beurre
alors on va
Ikaru Nakamura le streamer américain
qu'est-ce qui nous fait c'est fort
comment il a fait ça il a fait ça comme
ça il y a 7 minutes contre 6 secondes
il a fait qu'une bouchée
regardez-moi ça les dames j'ai trois là
qui arrive ça va faire mal dame j'ai
trois même pas besoin regardez et puis
fais rien d'exceptionnel ça a l'air
tellement facile quand c'est joué par
ces joueurs là mais ça l'est pas
croyez-moi
et il a plu il a plus de temps en plus
ok ok ok
et ça fait 1-0 pour les Gotham Knight
bravo et car on Nakamura superbe partie
[Musique]
parce que c'est quand même la partie
sympa de la ronde là il y a pas une
partie entre
comme est-ce que tu veux jouer alors pas
possible j'ai une matériel de d'avance
avec les autres tu pourras rendre un
petit peu mais mais tu as trop de
problèmes quand même tu peux pas jouer
ça quoi que
mais bon c'est
cavaliers B6
et en fait tu fais une découverte mais
je t'attaque toujours tout
genre un truc comme ça c'est hyper
bizarre mais j'ai l'impression qu'à la
fin tu te retrouves avec des pièces en
moins quand même
orange
on est dans le sacrifice dedans
il y avait une partie comme ça c'est qui
il y avait une partie comme un célèbre
enfin célèbre je vais sur internet
[Musique]
[Rires]
je sais plus un truc du genre avec un
tourage 2 comme ça
mais bon il y a tellement de choses
alors cavalier 4 jouer par jour elle
joue que des coups très très logique et
humains elle menace d'un prince et
quatre échecs qui pourrait faire très
mal et comment l'empêche je sais pas
ça
c'est
le coup de la même
ça rigole pas
tu parles la pièce
ça ne va pas
écoute j'ai envie de pleurer quoi
des scènes minimum j'ai ça quoi et ça a
l'air quand même
sur ça
c'est le mat donc attention à faire sur
je suppose que son idée c'est ça et là
d'après notre ami ordinateur
je ne la vois pas
c'est triste de pas voir les tactiques
surtout quand on sait qu'elles sont là
[Rires]
parce que certes les gagnants mais peu
beaucoup de temps la pendule quand même
à faire attention et allez vite
attention pour un champion du monde en
titre on le rappelle je vous donne jaune
qui est assez méconnu mais très très
fort joueuse moi je l'ai vu à
2555 c'est pas du tout son pic elle
avait pu moi j'ai joué contre Gibraltar
il avait plus de 2006 il y a quelques
années donc elle peut monter beaucoup
plus haut
on l'a vu dans les matchs précédents
mais tu mets tellement grosse pression
sur le long terme c'est quand même pas
mal
c'est simplement c'était d'un point
aussi ça et puis on a quand même éliminé
un bel attaquant ici donc elle a joué
fou prendre essaie d'abord car il est en
jouet qui prend les trois puis on prend
tout reprend pièce de moins mais le roi
toujours au centre évidemment si on
pouvait roquer avec les Noirs ça serait
merveilleux mais on ne peut pas le roi
bouger de nombreuses fois on rappelle
cette règle si vous avez bougé vos trois
ou votre tour vous pouvez plus OK
temps possible il y a la tour en prise
voilà donc elle est trop échec 3D 8
[Musique]
dommage par rapport à ce fou qui sortira
plus
ça cloué quand même le cavalier
qu'est-ce qu'on peut imaginer maintenant
à j'aime pas les blancs
de compensation et le roi va trouver un
abri par exemple avec kb6 roi B7 on le
voit on le voit qu'il va avoir un abri
il peut jouer rabaisser être ici botnik
et il est très très bien voir
complètement gagnant
ah ça pourrait être
cavalier il y a plus rien en fait c'est
un F2
attaque
comme ça
voilà c'est ça qui est des trois fait
tellement mal
que ça paraît ça paraît complètement
foutu pour la joueuse chinoise dame B5
qui ne jouait pas la 3 qui était aussi
trop dur trop dur tandis que fait le
ciel
il faut qu'il empêche le perpète s'il
arrive à enlever les chèques et bien il
va gagner parce qu'il aura une dame
d'avance c'est pas dit qu'il arrive à
enlever les chèques
parce qu'on joue peut-être dame F4 MT1
voilà
protégeant spion et peut-être créant une
embellie par là et donc comment faire
les échecs on va par là et c'est vrai
qu'on s'est sorti des échecs et on va
probablement gagner avec ce pion très
très avancé
ça pourrait ça pourrait être la
ça pourrait être dur là parce qu'on voit
4 2 vous avez le score en bas en bas du
stream vous avez le score global il y a
quatre deux déjà fait de CF qui est bien
cachée
de gagner là il faudrait gagner je vais
aller voir je vais aller discrètement
regarder pendant que tu
regardes mais elle est très difficile
cette fille elle est très très mal
apparemment selon la jauge voilà ça
pourrait faire un 4-0 ça serait
complètement incroyable ou la dame à
deux j'ai eu pendant 20 dixième de
seconde j'ai cru que d'abat de gagner
mais il y avait C4 a gagné la dame
ça fait un peu peur quand on va ce genre
de trucs et là c'est gagnant on va
simplement accompagner le pion il y a
plus de perpette le roi et beaucoup trop
centralisé pour qu'il y a un perpète
donc c'est terminé
et ouais ils sont bons les Gotham
Knights ça tu l'as dit en début la fête
finie est-ce que est-ce que ça serait
quand même une surprise énorme avec
cette Benoni qui payait pas de mine ouh
là là on va voir on va voir veilli parce
que franchement ça pourrait être le
franchement s'il y a 6-2 après c'est
plus là tu as passé et
[Musique]
là jusqu'à qui va arriver aussi le fou
qui va devoir laisser les cases noires
pas fini cette partie moi je te le dis
avec un pion comme ça
donc 3 0 5 2
alors là ça peut là ça peut se parler
très très vite en fait ce match si elle
gagne ici à Lina cette partie ça fait
6-2 il y aura deux points et demi à
mettre en deux sets
c'est très dur
je veux dire même moi je pourrais
rentrer
c'est pas trop quand même pas besoin
merci pour ta confiance
non non rajoute pas d'accord il y a plus
trop de suspense mais quand même alors
elle joue bien elle joue fort on peut
pas prendre parce qu'il y a la tour
là-bas il est là encore veilli il se bat
7 secondes contre 10 attention dans ce
design notre réciproque je elle est pas
du tout favorite Alina casting skyr on
va voir
mais elle est tellement gagnante
de beaucoup à faire avec les Blancs
[Musique]
que câlina mais bon la position souris
Alina pour l'instant
Damas 8 jouait attention Damas 8 menace
m'attendez attention à cacher
quand même
arrivé en plus derrière peut-être c'est
bon pour suspense c'est terminé d'après
la jauge j'ai 42 et oui je vous l'avais
dit que veilli enzynote contre Alina
était quand même gros gros favori et il
a gagné bravo à lui et bravo à nous
parce que ça nous fait plus de suspense
et on a même pas on n'aime pas Stéphane
qui va rentrer du coup
la bonne nouvelle il va rester avec moi
commenter et ça fait 5 3 pour les Gotham
Knights 3 5 3 bon du coup c'est j'ai
envie de dire que que les Chinois comme
ça pas mal dans le sens
parce que franchement
le cinquième que joue la plus gagné
aussi
il y a une grosse partie de jumju qui
est qui répète récompensé
parce qu'elle avait une position
vraiment monstrueuse c'est Juventus
parce que on a vu le scénario qui avait
3-0 et tout ça et que je vais jouer la
perd du temps mais objectivement je veux
une journal de mettre un point dans
cette partie et ça devrait faire quatre
partout bon écoute ça fait 5 3 mais rien
n'est terminé on va voir les joueurs bon
évidemment avec un aka comme ça autant
en forme ça va être compliqué quand même
pour pour les Chinois
ils sont ils sont en retards ces chinois
ils ont battu Blitz à la
au match précédent donc on va voir tout
ça on va faire
les deux premiers sont en forme Naka et
fedo c'est très dur pour les Chinois
parce qu'en fait ils sont ils ont ils
ont pas de stars tu vois pas de stars
voilà ils ont ils ont envoyé mais oui il
est pas très en forme en ce moment on
l'a vu encore la semaine dernière contre
Blitz qui était pas des bonnes parties
pas des bons scores et du coup il est il
est pas hyper en forme je trouve en tout
cas c'est peut-être pas un format qui le
réussit beaucoup et contre fedo et enaka
ben je sais pas on va voir un petit peu
ce qui se passe on va faire un micro
break je te propose restez bien avec
nous on est là jusqu'au jusqu'à la fin
de ce match évidemment ensuite pour
suivre l'équipe de Blitz sur Blitz
stream mais merci de nous suivre et on
revient dans quelques petites minutes là
tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour donc dans ce
match de proces League semaine 3 comme
vous le voyez en haut avec ce match
incroyable entre Hikaru
Nakamura les Gotham Knights et cette
équipe chinoise et oui ou comme vous
pouvez le voir je fais au minimum 15 cm
de plus que Stéphane et non c'est juste
je veux en fait c'est ça n'a rien à voir
avec ça mais voilà on voit un très beau
match et les Gotham Knights Stéphane qui
sont dominateurs pour l'instant surtout
cette partie un petit peu charnière
entre botnik et Juventus très belle
attaque de Juventus à la fin
ouais c'est un peu dommage c'était
vraiment la le prix de beauté annoncé
de Juan qui finalement a été très
imprécise et
ça va te retourner complètement donc
ouais partie un peu difficile pour les
Chinois du coup qui sont menés
maintenant 3 ans dans ce match donc ça
fait 5 3 au score final et est-ce que je
voulais le jeu n'aurai pas le redoutable
privilège d'affronter le streamer
américain
l'ogre d'Internet
Ikao Nakamura
[Musique]
elle a les blancs je pense qu'elle
double est blanc notre ami non je pense
que c'est une aka qui double et blanc
tous les jours c'est rare qui
s'ysprime pas c'est que vraiment
il se passe un truc il y a un problème
quand il y a des événements etc il
engage des gens pour stream sur sur son
twitch c'est ça et donc c'est vraiment
une chaîne qui est vivante qui est
quasiment tout le temps tout le temps en
ligne et d'où elle rigole encore
on dirait on va voir
donc on va voir pour l'instant j'ai pas
les coups mais ça va pas tarder et ça
sera important de d'arrêter Hikaru alors
peut-être essayer de jouer un peu plus
solide pour Juventus dans cette partie
parce que Hikaru va prendre des risques
forcément et ça peut lui jouer des tours
et on voit et non et oui tu as raison et
voilà
icarbonak à moi qui joue une beaucoup
lui au bœuf
elle connait elle fait G3 fougères
on va voir il y a plusieurs plans
ensuite petit rock petit ah non il fait
à 5 pour protéger son pion le plan
standard c'est de faire Dame des trois
quais BD2 et ensuite 4
mais on peut aussi commencer par un
petit coup de A3 non elle fait Dame des
trois à l'ancienne juventsun
c'est considéré comme étant un peu mieux
pour les blancs après petit rock on peut
faire des plans comme ça
qui est BD7 et en général c'est le
cavalier on arrivera jamais jouer à
jouer 5 donc on replace ce cavalier pour
éventuellement quand les Noirs vont
faire le 5 bondir sur des 5 avec le
cavalier c'est la case du cavalier en
fait aussi bizarre que ça puisse
paraître
c'est comme ça des 6 E4 il fait 5
profitant du fait que le Fou est pas
défendu ici du cavalier pas défendu si
on fait puis on prend puis on prend
l'impression de gagner un pion mais on
gagne rien du tout on perd un cavalier
donc après le 5
et là elle fait à 3 donc elle fait tout
autre elle mixe un petit peu les plans
que j'ai donné cavalé à 6 est-ce qu'on
va voir droit à cavalier cavalier C2
c'est normalement ce qu'on fait dans ce
genre de structure
il fait le il fait le chaud
de connaître alors que normalement c'est
plutôt un joueur de gambidam tout à fait
standard
Iker ou Nakamura mais là il a envie
c'est clairement une indication à ce
faux B4 échecs même si c'est pas le plus
agressif au monde
c'est clairement quelque chose qui
montre qu'il a envie de d'avoir une
partie qui va où il aura des chances de
gagner
on va la laisser réfléchir on a d'autres
très beaux apparemment on avait eu quand
on fait nos CIF par exemple à
l'échiquier numéro 2 ça c'est peut-être
la partie de la ronde enfin remarque la
champion du monde contre Naka c'est pas
mal aussi faut avouer que c'est
intéressant
donc du coup ça c'est une partie hyper
importante pour les Chinois parce que
c'est leur leader qui joue contre un
autre gros leader ou on a la vente de
Moscou avec fush 4 attention il faut
sept ouh là là
le fameux G5 défense C4 c'est ça ah bah
oui des Français
4g5 faut j'ai trois B5 c'était très très
à la mode fin des années début des
années
2000 début des années 2010 il y avait
beaucoup beaucoup de lignes j'ai passé
des longues après-midi à étudier ça avec
Vladimir cramique
et c'est chaud ce que j'avais retenu
c'est que c'est quand même c'est quand
même c'est sacrément dur à jouer pour
les Noirs je trouve
avec les Noirs ça donne ça donne pas du
tout envie et ça a été repris il y a eu
des parties d'alfa0 depuis dans son
match contre stockfish avec les Blancs
qui a qui a montré des choses assez
incroyables il jouait avec le pion de
moins avec les Blancs et il se presse
pas il joue très positionnel très calme
enfin c'est assez assez grandeur et là
en fait on joue un gambidame ma
grand-mère du pauvre avec ce pion en C6
normalement c'est pas une c'est pas une
super ligne pour les Noirs ok BD7 mais
bon ça reste en gambida mais ça reste
très très solide même si c'est vrai
qu'on aimerait parfois jouer ces 7c5 en
un seul coup et ça va forcer les Noirs à
prendre en ces quatre à un moment et à
jouer B5 et fou B7 qui est aussi une
ligne assez solide
donc assez solide pour l'instant ok
après je pense que le CF il a plus
intérêt à essayer que le solide avec les
noirs et vous voyez ils ont peut-être
prendre l'avance clairement je crois
qu'il a l'air assez intéressant en tout
cas tout à fait
peut-être à Lina Kim skaya contre lou
youpi elle nous montre
une bonne fête elle fait chaud elle fait
chauffer la prépa
contre 7,45 déjà elle est
dans sa prépa ça c'est clair donc on
voit une bonne Feld et ce petit coup H4
qui vient qui vient un peu maintenant
tout le temps dans ses grandes Feld avec
H4 H5 et voilà on a pas peur d'amassin
pour F1 c'est connu ce truc on va faire
H5 c'est très très chaud pour les Noirs
faut savoir ce qu'on fait quand on
commence à réfléchir comme ça c'est
quand même plutôt très très mauvais
signe parce que Alina elle va connaître
c'est une évidence
c'est pas de tour des 8 coups je sais
pas
ah tes souhaits
c'est très apprécié
donc pour moi je sais pas pour les gens
mais merci beaucoup
donc ouais H5 et 100 euros
4 je ramène la dame peut-être un coup de
5 et ça peut être très très chaud et
d'ailleurs il fait dommage
5e
ce qu'il a prévu après 3 qui peut
menacer G4 ou kg 3 et H5 et ta dame est
quand même est très très bizarre ici et
attention j'ai peut-être des dessins
aussi qui te coupent la dame en fait tu
vois qui peuvent vraiment te prendre la
dame sèche
en fait et alors là bon peut-être pas
maintenant parce que là du coup je
préfère cavalie F4 mais genre froid avec
l'idée de jouer de jouer je trouve G5 et
là j'ai kabalé G3 ou cavalier F4 qui va
te manger la dame F3 d'ailleurs je pense
que après damage 5 F3 il faut G5 est une
très très grosse menace
il se met dans le il se met dans les
soucis d'entrée
bon ça va pas du tout quoi
alors ça c'est moi je vais faire au
moins ça voilà j'encaisse le pion
normalement quoique
jouer alors
c'est quoi le
c'est quoi c'est quoi le délire
curieux va-t-elle jouer fouger 5 bizarre
parce que
c'est une idée quoi enfin t'as pas 36
possibilités
quand tu fais F3
mais qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire je
comprends pas
je vois pas on va mettre on va mettre
notre le Dieu le Dieu vivant stock fish
alors peut-être je pensais à un cavalier
au 5
[Musique]
jouer pour le public pour choisir
Stéphane si on joue soit le spectacle
soit les points c'est dur c'est rare de
faire les deux
c'est il y a quelques-uns F2 ah quel
dommage mais bon c'est très bien
c'était vérifié par la jauge j'ai
vérifié avec les bars c'est plus 3,50
donc bon
la dernière partie est bonjour à
fatoumodo
qui va plus dire qu'il va punir les gens
dissipés dans le chat attention salut
aussi Joseph qui est sur le sur le
il est là et oui notre ami de Marseille
le limougeot Marseillais tu connais
cette c'est une race très très unique
c'est
de Limoges et de Marseille en même temps
c'est spécial sans l'accent il y a pas
l'accent pas encore
alors botnik avec mes
bêtises j'en
perds4 qui va arriver tout à 14 c'est le
transfert
d'être clair
ça a l'air pas mal
donc bon ouais mais c'est solide pour
une heure j'aime bien les Noirs ici
concrètement
tu peux avoir des problèmes quand même
plus tard
et on pourra quatre tours G4 je l'ai vu
venir tu vois enfin je sens que je vais
je vais trouver un truc pour le parrain
par exemple tu auras 4 F6
ah oui ça fait beaucoup de ça fait
beaucoup de tours
je suis pas connecté avec mon truc de
modo mais le tunes typiquement enfin
typiquement ce serait pas passé avec moi
donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait là il est moins
bien votre nid que je trouve qu'il
j'aime pas du tout son début moi aussi
bien pour le suspense
après
il fait des trucs très classe sur le
long terme en fait
elle est pas très belle c'est très
solide chez les Noirs
ultra solide
la France a joué à 19h sur
on va voir Naka là parce que Naka c'est
avec nous mais alors
il a passé la première il joue vite
qu'est-ce qu'il fait vite
[Musique]
l'impression qu'en fait c'est trop
facile quoi il est en train d'apprendre
là il est complètement gagnant il a pris
il est incroyable
icarbonakamura
donc je me demandais si vraiment ok
c'est un flingueur quoi
alors
peut-être tomber aussi alors qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on met le cœur des quatre on
joue l'épicerie en échange de cavalier
mais ce cavalier menace
donc j'ai envie de pousser les cheveux
je te remercie ça veut dire ça veut dire
que je suis un joueur pas actif non non
c'est le truc poli voilà sois poli soit
poli tu dis que je suis un joueur
professionnel
le spectacle ou les points Stéphane
c'est comme ça
c'est professionnel voilà c'est le mot
que je cherche c'est juste avant coup en
fait
donc je me laisse mes trois je te
conseille de faire tomber mais ton verre
je vais mettre
est-ce que est-ce que j'ai pas du dessin
alors attends peut-être que c'est c'est
un peu tout moche
c'est c'est moi j'aime bien jouer comme
ça un peu sale ça va fort quand même
bien
B5 s'éperon est interdit à cause du
courage et du vis-à-vis sur la bourse et
du coup bah alors là je mange tout de
suite on est obligé de s'organiser parce
que là on peut pas laisser faire ça ou
ça donc on est obligé de prendre et à 4
et maintenant les deux pions passés liés
c'est quand même la clé du succès en
général
dire que que généralement topion sur la
troisième ça c'est fort qu'une tour
donc là j'ai une dame et deux pions et
on va voir va-t-il faire le coup du le
coup du peureux le coup du joueur pro ou
le coup champagne et on a la réponse
Stéphane devine non
[Musique]
dans l'idée que j'aurais dû rentrer quoi
c'est sûr en fait ah mais regarde
la pauvre elle est elle est vraiment
réduite à faire des coups d'attente et
on regarde vas-y je te ramène le roi
donc dame à trois d'abord ou attaque la
tour attaque le pion
c'est complètement
de rien en fait elle gagne le père elle
rigole c'est bien elle abandonne et
c'est une victoire du caronakamura une
victoire sèche très sèche 6 3
pour les Gotham Knight c'est alors
maintenant plus le droit à l'erreur pour
les Chinois ça c'est une certitude
avoir que si il faut encore 2 et demi
sur trois le match est terminé le match
est terminé donc à 8h30 on n'aura pas le
quatrième 7 s'il y a deux sur trois pour
pour les les côtes am nights après bon 8
et demi je crois que c'était une seule
fois pour l'instant dans la compétition
cette année d'avoir un match terminé
avant l’œuf et je crois que c'était
Gotham light
il a un pion de plus le cavalier
complètement aux fraises puis on passait
protéger les finales sont archi
gagnantes dans le 4 pourrait arriver
qui était très bien tout à l'heure on se
rappelle qu'à simcaille et aussi
complètement gagnant regardez elle a
fait le tour H4 pour faire tour à champ
mais là c'est quoi ça sent la et fais de
CF lève le point donc à priori il a
gagné
et donc ça va faire
il faut les voir portnica c'est parti tu
fais nul en fait j'ai terminé
parce que là tu as même si c'est ma
comparable
c'est complètement terminé donc potnique
il allait il allait Blanco
je trouve pas votre nick il est là et il
a les contre souilly
et donc voilà botnik doit faire nul dans
cette position qui ma foi paraît
ça me prend mes trois pas trop leur
possible parce que je peux prendre il y
a maths et surpuis on prend et au
minimum la nul mais
beaucoup plus fort on ramasse une pièce
nette
alors pour l'instant il gagne rien
Florent les prix je les ai pas montré
mais 150 000 dollars de prix au total
donc pour l'instant il gagne rien mais
je crois que une place en quart de
finale assure déjà un prix pour l'équipe
alors après comment se débrouille les
équipes
pour la répartition des prix et bien ça
c'est les regarde
moi je me rappelle qu'il m'avait fait
j'avais joué norvégien donc il y avait
tout un truc il y a tout un truc hyper
précis en fonction du nombre de parties
jouées tu touchais tant et tant bon il y
a eu un seul souci c'est qu'on a rien
gagné du tout et donc du coup cette
vraie c'est brillant calcul et quand
même tombé à l'eau
mais voilà donc c'est le premier souci
c'est quand même c'est de commencer par
gagner après
H6 jouer
sur ses points F7 comme tout à l'heure
OK et là il peut y avoir du regard du
dames 8 suivi de cavaler.f6 bon ça
marche pas il y a encore le fou contre
la fuite
ouais mais est-ce qu'il y a besoin de
s'énerver autant là enfin je veux dire
on est même pas moins bien alors je sais
qu'on voit la situation du match mais en
fait il y a pas besoin de s'énerver les
les blancs sont pas moins bien selon moi
[Musique]
parce qu'en fait ok bon
il y a encore fait de CF il y a un point
et demi à mettre en six parties regarde
là il est pas moins bien parce qu'après
puis on prend il peut aller il peut
aller s'amuser prendre les pions prendre
un petit pion botnique il joue même ce
qui aurait pas la gagne ici
ça joue la gagne c'est vite dame prend
les 7 je vois pas dans quel monde bon
bah il y a d'avocat hein ça va être
perpète mais
il y a pas de raison qui soit moins bien
et donc ça serait incroyable et cashing
Skye qu'elle termine notre travail
finalement ça joue sur Kalys quand un
dernier set ou pas bien je ne crois pas
10 secondes de la pendule en plus pour
Louis giping je crois pas
à 19h
alors on va aller voir
dans la fin de cette partie
elle réfléchit face à Louis ping
il est dans le dur
alors après c'est pas complètement si je
fais ça toi je faisais pas
par ça
[Musique]
qui gagne aussi facile
après je te raconte pas je te raconte
pas le truc
bon tout gagne tout gagne pour Alina
casting
fait nul à cette partie le match est
terminé c'est hyper ça je joue la
dernière mais franchement
c'est le troisième match ça ferait deux
fois sur trois qui terminent avant ta
recette
à l'avoir fait et ils le font deux fois
complètement hallucinant
dame 4 et nul et il y a même pas à jouer
le dernier match va-t-il le faire par
équipe il est normalement obligé hein
c'est tellement c'est faute
professionnelle de pas jouer dans le 4
ici
je pense que là il va se regarder le
match regarder le soir du match est-ce
qu'il regarde en direct au troisième
match c'est bizarre de regarder au
troisième c'est tu t'attends pas quand
même à ce qui est 3-0 tu vois c'est bon
il a pas regardé
alors peut-être ça sera incroyable si
perd cette partie et qui perde le match
derrière ça vaut une cote là
ok ça serait beau même là dans le cadre
de faire nul hein
apparemment a gagnante d'après la jauge
ou en tout cas très bonne mais c'est
vrai que c'est bizarre cette décision
avec le roi qui peut d'apprendre
les points le spectacle
je répéterai jamais assez
mais ouais en plus ils ont gagné non
mais là je plaisante bien évidemment et
en plus ils ont gagné avec style quand
même c'est là tu as 8 points tu vois il
joue pas de petit bras
et je joue tellement pas petit moi que
là il doit faire nul il avait un perpète
il a même pas pris
là tu manges quand même et sur et
comment toujours après
je peux faire H4 H5 temps
[Musique]
ça
va c'est être une course il a joué
qu'est-ce qui fait il fait de héros 4
c'est la partie row F7 va être jouée
quoi d'autre et H4 jouer il joue bien en
plus ce botnique t'avais raison
ça fait 3 1 4 0
ça va faire 9 3 9 3 une
raclée comme on envoie un peu et la
grosse info ça va être les Gotham
Knights pour ceux qui en doutaient sont
qualifiés sont officiellement très
officiellement dans quelques secondes
qualifiées pour les quarts de finale on
ira voir ce classement
et là c'est tristesse là j'ai 6 h 5 puis
on prend puis on prend et on a les trous
sur la case F5 G6 pour ramener le roi je
peux si je peux tenter ça mais ça va
être ça va être juste
et on arrive avec un peu de retard
malheureusement pas
sch8 il a joué
notre ami chinois H5 va arriver bien
évidemment
et c'est officiel 4-0 c'est marqué il y
a le spoiler qui arrivait mais bon toute
façon on l'avait annoncé depuis
longtemps
et ranger 6 et c'est parti ah bah dis
donc quelle performance majuscules
Gotham Knight
franchement
c'est une très très belle équipe
c'est terminé regardez on va se faire un
petit point
un petit point classement et Gotham
light qui passe donc à trois victoires
c'est pas complètement
update mais voilà c'est officiel ils
sont qualifiés pour les quarts de finale
avec les Indian yugiz les Shanghai Tiger
ce qui reste quand même très bien avec
deux victoires et une défaite comme les
gnomes
et les lévitovs et les canards et
peut-être et peut-être Blitz
ou pas
à 19h sur la chaîne blitstream contrôler
les croatiennes bouledogs donc encore
une fois une grosse équipe en fait
peut-être vous montrer un petit peu les
les compos du match donc côté France
je vais les mettre à l'écran comment je
vais faire je vais vous mettre ça tout
de suite comme ça on va pouvoir voir
je vais faire
je t'entends plus
avoir à l'écran désolé je m'attendais
pas à ce que ça soit aussi rapide
a commencé en stream d'ailleurs il est
prêt il est là
allez-y dès maintenant et on va vous
montrer tout de suite évidemment les
appareils
et on va faire
comme ça et vous les avez donc
c'est ça donc du coup côté Blitz c'est
gris Chuck mvl Maëlle et démantèle donc
très très gros équipe et alors que chez
les Bulldogs on a Bogdan Daniel donc des
hack qui est un jeune talent de 18 ans
je crois maintenant 2700 Elo on a injeek
qui est aussi un jeune talent maintenant
maintenant il a grandi mais il est passé
grand maître à cette eau aussi et on
avait aussi un escort qu'on avait déjà
commenté et je crois qu'il avait été pas
mal du tout ça avait été un c'est un
genre qui a 2500 euros en fait il les
mettent international mais la 2500 hello
3000 et lots en blitz sur toscom donc
c'est pas un peintre et du coup bah
Polina chubalova qui on en a parlé aussi
pas mal la dernière fois
vos stylo aussi et donc ça va être un
match
très chaud alors une chic c'est un
particularité d'être le plus plus grand
grand maître au monde
mais
en tout cas il est il est immense il
fait 2 mètres
vraiment c'était crotte
c'est hyper bizarre donc
je l'avais besoin un tournoi il avait 14
ou 15 ans et il était déjà plus rock moi
quoi
j'ai juste ça récemment bon c'est pas ça
pas beaucoup d'intérêt mais en tout cas
une petite c'est vraiment je pense qu'il
fait demain
il fait plus de 2 m ça c'est
100%. et ouais donc gros match et match
qui s'annonce très serré et palpitant
tout à fait
et
je vous invite à aller voir du coup la
chaîne Blitz stream pour suivre tout ça
ça commence dans 50 minutes donc il y a
un petit peu le temps tranquille et puis
écoute nous je sais pas si on se
retrouvera
on sait pas on a pas encore les infos
dans tous les cas écoute moi je trouve
ça à tous de passer une très bonne fin
de semaine et moi je retrouve quand même
les gens demain à 16h30 avec Kevin
alors attendez je vais vous dire je vais
vous dire parce que du coup j'ai rien
préparé
qui est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on stream
demain je vais te le dire tout de suite
demain on a les California unicornes
contre la team des Indiens MGD 1 alors
California unicornes leur premier échec
qui est c'est Google et mgda la première
échiquier c'est bon ça va être Google
ça va être pas mal ça va être très très
sympa ce match de demain donc demain
16h30 mais tout de suite c'est à 19h sur
blit stream n'hésitez pas allez
encourager nos frenchies
voilà bah merci à tous on souhaite une
excellente soirée et puis bah très très
bientôt et à les Blitz allez bonne
chance ciao ciao